[Applause]
i do think golden microphones make me
rap better
this one's we're going to get
suggestions from you anything you want
to rap about we'll start we'll start
with this side of the room anyone
doesn't know
do you say flossing
pubes flossing okay so you mean
using pubes to floss right
yeah
that's quite resourceful guys i don't
know why we're laughing
pube flossing
is that just something you've made up or
is it something that you're like trying
to get to catch on
you've been thinking about it for a
while really
you would because you were quite quick
with it i was like well in this section
it's my time to shine
pubes flossing
pubes flossing i like it um do a
particular color of cube that you want
us to
salt and pepper ginger who knows right
okay pube flossing let's come to the
middle of the room and there's a hand up
there yes
okay
can can someone
can someone with an english accent say
what you just said
it's latin for what
oh [ __ ] oh i wish i'd actually got you
because that was [ __ ] oh [ __ ] i
literally was talking to my wife about
this about a week ago
why did you all laugh how did you all
know that has that been a thing that's
been brought up recently
no okay because it's from a carthaginian
piece which is where you inflict such a
horrible
defeat upon your enemy like carthage had
to ask rome for permission to wage war
didn't they what was the name of the
senator who said it
okay to the elder [ __ ] [ __ ] hate
myself now
um this side of the room suggestion not
as hard as that one though
uh something you say strawberry fudge
is that what you said or did you say
something like tax refund it was just
hard for me to hear
scurry
again like i think
carthage must be destroyed pube flossing
so far these are actually pretty good
well done
i mean it's taken twice as long as it
should do but
this side of the room let's get another
suggestion
is that a hand up yeah
sorry insurance premium on the left
testicle of boris johnson okay
what what what
what happened to his
has there been breaking news
insurance premium on boris johnson's
left testicle and then let's we'll come
back to the middle for this one um yeah
hand up there
a mexican standoff during a colonoscopy
okay
okay so who's who's the third person in
the room
i guess the anesthetist right because
you would be you are anesthetized for a
colonoscopy i presume i mean you know
you don't have to be if you like it it's
it just does sound like it's quite
painful okay scurry funge
carthage must be destroyed pube flossing
or john's left testicle insurance
premium mets can stand off during a
colonoscopy for those of you
i don't know if you know what that means
that's like when you've got all your
guns
like reservoir dogs
cool great okay cool this is these are
good suggestions well i'll do my best to
do justice to them
if any of this rap is [ __ ] it was
inspired by you so it's your fault
have some fun with it
[Music]
oh yeah i'm jigging i'm jigging
my guy wise in the role with the front
rapping in a different language that's
latin back in the days i went for sure
kate told that eldor says to emperors
and those guys in the senate don't be
offended but carthage must be crossed we
must end it burn it to ash to rubble
because all the carthaginians they give
us trouble or maybe cast asians i'm not
so sure they were over there and wrong
trying to wage a war i think defeated a
trio of times three times crushed under
roman sandals like mine they'd be back
in the day not easy you can see the
romans there with the bc maybe with the
ed it's a mystery i mean a.d not edy i
stick to these that's erectile
dysfunction i had a big luncheon and now
i feel food in my teeth crouching i try
and get it out but i am at a loss i'm in
the bathroom cabinet no floss where's it
gone the cupboard there is bare i look
down to my underwear and their tear i'm
of the age that i can use this plucking
out those hairs that are pubic much
better than a toothpick when i stretch
people think it's so gross that they
start to wretch but no it helps me i
should really warn i always get stuck
between my teeth popcorn so i pop it out
and what do i use doesn't matter whether
it's black brown or ginger pubes but if
you've got none down below like maybe
you're going through the chemo therapy
and you can get the testicular cancer
boris johnson's insurance client's got
the answer he walks in he says don't
you'll see them i've got silly hair my
insurance premiums are so high oh yes
i'd be finished there i used to be the
prime minister at number 10 but now and
again i'd go out have sex with many
women how many children have i got eight
or nine i use all of the sperm that's
deep inside my left testicle the right
one so [ __ ] i think of maggie thatcher
it goes up and i erupt i'm a
conservative i need to pay lots of cash
a preservative make sure i can put my
penis in their [ __ ] how much do i pay a
hundred pounds a month that's the
premium that he uses it's easier guy at
the back person comes over sees you
you're like oh [ __ ] it's such a mess
i've got to run around the house and get
dressed i'm looking over here i like to
scour the oven hood what we call this
scurry fudge scurry bunch i don't even
know it's a word that you made that be
you a life y'all know it's a dutch word
everybody's [ __ ] scurry fun funny from
the side of your head it's so enjoyable
your cleanings your house are to do with
your words they're in your mouth is this
action good i don't even know but you're
enjoying it like yes here at the show
last thing that we need to do we did the
balls and the pube that we took from you
again remind me what it was it's gone
oh yes how of course how can we forget
i'm there at the little proctologist he
says yes chris i know that you're one
wishes for me to examine inside your
jewelry look at your appendix now that i
have seen them in income a [ __ ]
burglar for sure he kicks down the
window he breaks down the door he pulls
out a shotgun sawn off at the tip and
i'm like careful doc don't slip and i
whip out just a handful of poo i hurl it
at the man his face goes blue the
doctor's got the probe with the [ __ ]
upon the end and the other one a scalpel
it depends there we go and afterwards we
clean our hands off and that's the
colonoscopy the mexican standoff
[Applause]